die Machtübernahme der Taliban hat die
Welt schockiert im Sommer 2021
für Frauen ist die Lage mittlerweile
hoffnungslos der letzte Taliban Erlass
kam zu Weihnachten Frauen wird die
Arbeit in Hilfsorganisationen verboten
hunderttausende viniopharmadi können so
nicht mehr erreicht werden wie viele
andere Frauen ist die mit ihren drei
Kindern auf sich alleine gestellt ihr
Mann ist im Iran fremde Männer dürfen
keine Hilfe leisten mitten in einem
Winter in dem eine Hungersnot droht
wir brauchen Hilfe sagt sie die
Situation dürfte jedem auf der Welt klar
sein wir stehen hier vor dem
Zusammenbruch
nach dem letzten talibanellas stellen
einige Hilfsorganisationen ihre Arbeit
vorübergehend ein weil sie ohne Frauen
nicht arbeitsfähig sind und Deutschland
kündigt an Hilfszahlungen zu stoppen um
den Druck auf die Taliban zu erhöhen wir
müssen Hilfe jetzt erstmal aussetzen und
dann gemeinsam
international abstimmen wie wir weiter
vorgehen weil wir brauchen die Frauen
dort vor Ort wir brauchen sie in der
Arbeit und ohne Frauen ist da kein Staat
zu machen wenn sie Hilfe aussetzen
treffen sie damit auch die Ärmsten der
Armen können Sie das verantworten ja das
ist genau das Dilemma indem wir da sind
wir wollen vor Ort helfen aber wir
brauchen für diese Hilfe Frauen die dort
aktiv sind die häufigste Antwort auf die
Frage was tun in Afghanistan lautet in
Berlin Dilemma
in einer Situation in der man gezwungen
ist sich zwischen zwei gleichermaßen
unangenehmen Dingen zu entscheiden hat
die Bundesregierung sich vorläufig
entschieden kein Geld es gibt darauf
kaum Reaktionen im sonst lauten
Regierungsviertel mit dem Thema lässt
sich politisch nichts gewinnen wir haben
geglaubt dass man mit Beschwörungen und
mit Gutmenschentum und Hoffnungen die
Taliban ja wie soll ich sagen
beschwichtigen kann sie haben Stück für
Stück alle Versprechen gebrochen und
unterdrücken die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
deshalb glaube ich es ist sehr wichtig
dass die Bundesregierung dass die
Außenministerin zu einer nüchternen
Realpolitik zurückkehren die Druck auf
die Taliban ausüben die Druckmittel
gegenüber solchen Regime wie den Taliban
aber auch dem schrecklichen
Machthabern im Iran sind natürlich
begrenzt aber umso mehr muss man all das
was geht auch nutzen um Druck auszuüben
nutzt die Bundesregierung wirklich alles
was geht nach dem überstürzten Abzug aus
Afghan kann und dem Drama um die
ortskräfte hat es lange gedauert bis ein
Aufnahmeprogramm stand das bis heute nur
schleppend funktioniert die deutsche
Botschaft in Kabul ist sowie andere
westliche Botschaften geschlossen trotz
Forderungen aus der UN auf
Wiedereröffnung
es gibt einen Untersuchungsausschuss und
eine onkett-kommission jeder weiß wie
langwierig deren Arbeit sein kann
und die Außenministerin äußert sich
pflichtschuldig immer mal wieder zur
Kämpferin für die rechtelosen Frauen
wird sie nicht so brutal dieser
russische Angriffskrieg ist wir
verlieren nicht den Blick für die Lagen
anderer Menschen in andere Regionen
dieser Welt nächste Woche Reisen
hochrangige Vertreter der Vereinten
Nationen nach Kabel und ich hoffe
einfach dass ich auch eine
Bundesregierung mit dem mit dem großen
Gewicht des Deutschland hat auf der
internationalen Bühne hier auch mit
einbringt armut Hunger Menschenrechte
und es geht weitere Herausforderungen
warum der Westen sich von Afghanistan
nicht abwenden darf hier steht für die
Europäer wie für die Amerikaner eine
zentrale Rolle zu unterbinden das
Afghanistan ein Ort ein Ort des
Terrorismus wird und deshalb ist man
auch darauf angewiesen mit den Taliban
weiter zu sprechen
die Nachrichten die aus Afghanistan
kommen in diesen Tagen sind nicht gut
aber die Nachrichten die wir nach
Afghanistan schicken sind es auch nicht